[Music]
oh yeah that's right
foreign
yes sir
it's my favorite time of year when Jay
uses to come bomb back from the grave
Mark bro burn on this day bro you're
[ __ ] your Jesus Takes were so edgy
apparently for like the weirdest people
yes sir because like hear him again
there's still hella people in like my
TTS and my donors and my stream they
come in they're like you don't co-sign
this right I'm like bro you're a fan I'm
like I'm like brah Muslim leave me out
of this I don't care okay wait yes
people are saying you up demanding you
make me apologize yeah but it's like
funny because it's not like it's never
gonna gain momentum because like on its
face what you did is a good thing right
like that's how Christianity kind of
started yeah so like most people don't
care also because they're like yeah
that's like fictional stuff who cares
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists yeah
yeah to me that's one of the funniest
things that people got mad at me and and
the people have been mad at me for a lot
of stuff yeah everybody just wants to be
Muslims so bad they're like whoa whoa
hold on like you can't you can't you
can't get mad like oh hold on now you
can't desecrate our profit I'm like bro
that's that's the Muslim stuff like you
don't you know what's funny about that
is that all like the most common retort
is like I dare you to do that against
Muhammad and see what happens yet
they're basically yeah they're doing the
same they're like yeah like Charlie ebdo
look like a good day
you know
anyway well today is our last
leftovers of the year
you know it's a bummer then we're taking
a break actually tomorrow Friday is our
last in studio podcast and then on
Tuesday is our live show and then we're
taking a break
are you taking any time off this year
[ __ ] no hell no brother I never take
time off dude they and sleep yeah yeah
the devil works but I work harder I just
I don't know I mean I love my job it's
not even a job you don't ever want to
just take a couple days no
um but I may be traveling more in the
upcoming year potentially I want to go
to like different countries yeah but are
you going to do like IRL streams there I
will probably stream a little bit but
it's never going to be the same as like
actually yeah you should enjoy yourself
a little bit actually like you know
doing desktop streams and stuff The
Curse Of Our Lives prep more years
because you're even single you don't
even have kids or you don't have kids
right and so um it's like we have
money and youth and theoretically time
you just gotta make time but I I but the
way I see it is like people are used
right guys I have youth yeah the way
the way I see it you are in a different
predicament like you you actually have
obligations you have children you have
like you know you also have this entire
process yeah so it's like hard to just
you know stop doing stuff you know what
I mean when you have early employees for
me it's like I could literally just
right stop it like that but
um I just love doing what I do well
that's good that's the main reason why I
don't want to stop is because I I love
doing what I do I love that yeah I love
that yeah just like Matt Healy and
Phoebe Bridgers and Bo Burnham okay like
being in a polycule I just got shocked a
little bit Bo Burnham friend of the show
is in an MMF friend of this show but not
like leftovers in particular because he
stopped responding to my DMs after
telling me that he was watching me
through quarantine teen and you know
that he's over it yeah he's seen it up
yeah he he because like
because like his special came out and
everyone's like oh my God Sako like he
sounds a lot like you Hassan blah blah
blah and I was like I DM him I was like
bro we met like a long ass time ago when
I was on The Young Turks like I love
your I love your stuff you know and and
you know I can can we be friends
and he was just like I'm I'm not very
available emotionally right now he's
like now I know why this [ __ ]
in a poly Q bro that's why he's
unavailable emotionally it doesn't make
you feel when he said when he rejected
why not me like I can overcome Matt
healy's stench I assume he smells you
want to be in Nepali I'll be in Nepali
you want to go MMF with Phoebe Bridger
yeah hell yeah I'll do it I understand
as you think there's a spare for a quad
or maybe of course yeah everybody always
says a quad is a crowd is that what they
say that's what yeah in the poly circus
sounds like you're turning me down yeah
I don't know I mean I I'm just just
shocked by these news so so this is not
political well maybe it is because
obviously Bo Burnham is a radical uh
liberal these are radical Marxist so Bo
Burnham that was third world so Bo
Burnham and a Paulie let's type this and
see this is huge news guys it's not
though because it's like the only
articles that have that I can find is
like a buzzfeed one
um with that information what you will
wait who posted it BuzzFeed posted it
yesterday Maddie shared this Instagram
photo of him closed I closed eye kissing
Phoebe of being embraced by a very
peaceful bow along with the caption gay
Poet's Society and the internet was
bewildered wait there's a photo of them
kissing so where is it
yeah drop that in the chat where is it
so I can avoid it I don't want to see it
oh good for you brother you're in a MMF
let's go yes sir
oh well here's this one I don't know
they're clearly very close I mean guys
hello what's going on why didn't you get
in there and just like also do a little
smooch in between yeah show them be the
alpha do they need Alpha Nepali or is it
all like dude I don't [ __ ] right okay
everything I see but listen no
disrespect to the paulies out there but
like polycule people are are like the
vegans of this generation or they like
can't shut the [ __ ] up about being poly
and they're so annoying about it usually
okay but like you know have fun as long
as oh this is the photo they're vegan
yeah okay they're V okay all right okay
anyway congratulations to Bo Burnham
Phoebe Bridgers Bridger and whoever the
[ __ ] this guy is oh man no offense to
Matt Huey it's 1947 or whatever the [ __ ]
come on according to this picture there
together
so rumor has it she's engaged what is
going on with this woman yeah it's very
confusing I don't know I'm not sure I'm
not sure I'm buying this uh this whole
Theory I got this Hollywood but Beau
does not seem like a Paulie person just
for my I could see intimate knowledge of
him because I think he I think he's uh
flex your internet should I should I
flex your intimate knowledge I think
he's too insecure I think he's too not
in like a he he's emotionally uh yeah we
saw the stand-up special too okay Ethan
no but no I don't know have you ever
hung out with him in person no because
like when I asked he just literally left
me yeah no because he responded to me
and we hung out
or I mean he came on the show
oh that's different you guys did not
hang out well before and after we spent
some good time together right there
that's yeah while he was leaving the
exiting the property no no
okay unrelated to the show did you guys
get to hang out in person yeah off
camera like away from the show not like
the night up not the day up no no he
means away from the studio away from the
studio like did you come to your house
as you go no that doesn't count
that doesn't count well I have a I have
a confidence I like to respect his
privacy his son and matters like this he
did he did hang a little bit longer than
most guests hang after the show so that
they're basically best friends
I mean why what is with you guys getting
the smallest [ __ ] pictures on
the internet
there's this I can't even see bro that's
one p that doesn't count he that doesn't
count he came to the Young Turk studio
and we hung out one time as well so it
didn't come for you came for Chang well
I'm the youngest dark so okay that's
fair actually so like you probably
thought it was me yeah he had no idea
who I was
um I was in the house
all right we got so much to get to
congratulations to Bo Burnham ladies and
gentlemen who's in a poly relationship
well we don't know fake news if it's you
know maybe it's not
oppose in the house yeah I had your
friend uh stavrosan yesterday we had a
great time yeah yeah we were we were I'm
a big boy I just want to state that one
more time for everyone to hear here like
it's you know people are saying that I'm
not a big boy and that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] why are you
come on man well with the emotional
music no it's just like I saw Dan wave
shaking his head yeah but he feels
you're full of [ __ ] bro why are you
doing fat boy Valor okay first of all
big boy doesn't necessarily just mean
fat but if we're gonna talk about body
fat percentage I am 100 firmly in the
big boy category with my body fat
percentage at least 20 body fat
first it was oh I'm going bald when you
have a luscious full head of hair now
you're not explaining dude
it's ridiculous I mean I I was going
ball I started taking medication for it
you know what I mean I I fixed it
it's not that it's a problem
not that it's a problem to be bald
someone offered to hook you up with
Santa Marin I don't know who that is but
apparently they're finished so they have
a connection do you know who that is yes
she's the Prime Minister okay so that's
pretty cool I mean you guys make it oh
she's actually really pretty yeah she's
like 36 years old she's married oh she
got she likes the party yeah
she got in trouble for like having a fun
night with her friends so are you is
there any interest here maybe I love her
but like also at the same time
um she's a bit of a lib but to live for
you she is cool though I mean she likes
the party she's too live for you
a little bit yeah he's with zelinski so
that I don't know if that makes you
insecure yeah I'm I'm big yeah I'm
insecure
yeah I'm a big supporter of Russia as
everybody knows so when I saw that I was
like oh not for me right yeah friends so
sorry Vladimir Putin yeah I love that
somebody oh my God me too
um I love the respect that uh he puts on
Vladimir's name and it's about time yeah
somebody does yeah well I mean he is a
Legend So Okay real recognize real you
really have 20 body fat where is it
aren't you like pretty lame no I'm not
that lame where's the fat I have a guy I
have yeah I have liver King back fat I
got love handles I got a bit of a gut I
don't see it bro I mean I have a bit of
a good like it's there's 20 I'm like 80
body fat there's just a little bit of
meat on me I mean that's I'm like a
slice of bacon
I I definitely I definitely am like
you know
20 body fat I don't believe that I'm 250
pounds like that's crazy you're like
you're like six I'm six four 250 pounds
I'm a big boy like it's big boy season
it's big boy status it's kind of wild I
guess I could hide it really well and
people say oh you're not a big boy but
like I'm not
I'm a big boy whatever bro you're like
oh my God I do 2 000 calories a day
I can't even have a taste of this
creamer in my coffee well that's true
which is because I'm desperately trying
to get out of Big Boy status I'm trying
to get into like you know hunky sexy man
status garthy you're doing fat fat
Stolen Valor and that's nothing true all
right listen speaking of uh big fatties
you had a dream that people called
answered the call your passion for baby
hippos yes was
um met with
your nipple bro oh my God
why is that one sexy like what's going
on it's like sensual dude I either gave
birth to that hippo or I'm doing like
awful things to it jrh I think you're
breastfeeding it okay now I feel like uh
AI art unethical okay firmly in the
unethical Camp I saw this one this one's
sick yeah that one's fine that one is
sick I have no idea what's going on in
your hand uh AI has a hard time have you
ever drawn
oh no I've never I used to draw look at
the hand yeah I used to draw all the
time hands are very difficult for a lot
of people including robots apparently
yeah well because the robot doesn't draw
it they're like stealing it from other
artists so
here you go
they captured your unibrow quite the
yeah that's kind of wild that they they
put the they really went for that one eh
yeah I guess I didn't shave it on that
day or something
um that hassle's so hot right now okay
oh [ __ ] oh that's an old ass photo
this one I'm not totally getting where
do they compile this image these images
from I think like I I know what photos
they're they're using It's a combination
of like old me and new me with the new
hair this photo makes no sense bro you
have three fingers you're whole you're
not even holding uh what's floating
decorative plate of a hippo but okay we
love it
not gonna be too hard on the robot
this one's pretty cool that one looks
like
that's just hippo me
you both have beautiful hair and so you
teamed up hippo in the himbo yeah oh my
God you're eating what the [ __ ] of a
hippopotamus
I would I would land gentle kisses on a
hippo though for sure on her butthole
like just no like on her on her little
snout you know what I mean on the little
nose area that's not where you're
kissing in this photo I mean I don't
know it's like
I would definitely kiss a hippo if I
knew that I wasn't gonna die I would I
would give little smooches
yeah actually maybe I get disgusted I
don't know because like they don't have
like fur nah they'd be cute they live in
the water they are so they're probably
all clean and nice you know what I mean
all right let's get to the uh the
animals that are in the water famously
don't smell bad
yeah I'm trying to be optimistic yeah
all right so let's get to some stuff
obviously today's our big
um show of the year we're going to teach
you guys what the holidays coming up uh
let's be let's not even say Hanukkah I'm
talking about Jesus I'm talking about
Christmas hell yeah brother there's a
war going on out here Brothers
they're trying to kill Christmas amen
and so as you sit around your Christmas
table we are arming you with the
knowledge
to uh repost to Perry
your misinformed conservative family is
that right sure yeah
and I will be cosplaying as Nathaniel
klansman uncle uncle Nathaniel
everybody's got an uncle Nathaniel
everyone and so and so Hassan will be
role-playing as you
so I'll do with that what you will
there's some stuff at the top of the
show I want to get to though have you
guys seen Trump's major announcement
super epic man he got it was so funny
people were like he's gonna run his
independent I was like no he's not
our speaker the house yeah yeah he's
gonna go for the speaker the house
position it's like that is so silly yeah
because there apparently you can be
president and speaker is that right yeah
speaker of the house technically as a
matter of fact does not even have to be
like a politician or an elected
representative like he could be just a
random dude oh that's a [ __ ] yeah
as long as you can get people to vote
for it so here he is yesterday he did
this Congress to vote for it I mean
there's a chance you're saying there's a
chance yes that's not
so they're saying so here's his big
announcement yesterday got all of his uh
fans super hype superhero
he's giving homelander Vibes so hard
right now oh is this Gonna Get Us
claimed this mute sound no I think it's
short enough though this is probably
yeah he has a major announcement
everybody gets [ __ ] excited I was
like I mean I I spend a little bit of
time yesterday talking about I was like
there's no way this is serious someone
was like he's gonna run as independent
like he's gonna run for Speaker of the
House well there's a prediction like
Scott Adams he's the Dilbert guy right
yeah people were talking about how this
is his VP pick so he's getting you know
he says let's see he already announced
so someone else is the superhero if it's
Carrie Lake the worst person ever who
lost thank God as his future running
mate you can throw away all the pulls
and your chessboard is already on the
floor whoa so he's attacking Carrie Lake
saying or is he saying like a trump
carry a trump link is it is like a
Checkmate immediate Checkmate yeah I
don't know is that sure his future
running mate you could throw away all
the polls and your chessboard is already
on the floor I think because he's just
confused he's like [ __ ] chess I'm
playing I'm going all-out War
it's a little it's a little murky I
can't tell if this is pro-trump or
anti-trump yeah it's a little murky but
I know Scott Adams is like a is a
hardcore Mega boy yeah He's a brave
truth teller which is funny
um Delbert uh
very funny comic by the way
but no the announcement came
um and it was actually
at the end of 2022
a nft collection for a hundred dollars
oh my god oh thank God everybody's been
waiting this is what I've been waiting
for it's like this is just made for me
100 bucks dude that's a good ass deal
yeah
she's like a year after everybody know
like Logan Paul is not getting into nft
did Logan Paul's dink doing tease
[ __ ] zip Zapped he's they made all
he's already rugged and pulled a
thousand times
[Music]
this is literally played in CIA black
sites revealed to reveal actionable
intelligence Yeah well yeah so here it
is here's his uh the ACLU will hear
about the crimes that you committed
sorry apologies to the ACLU please oh
yeah bro 100 but I thought when I first
watched it that I said 99 Cents I was
like oh that's how dare you that's a
very damn [ __ ] dare you dude 100
bucks you know it's not just the nft
though like you get like an hour on the
golf course which is such a funny chance
which is such a funny period of time
like why an hour like that's not how
long golf is right what do you get to
hit like two links
you get to play two holes with Donald
Trump which is funny because like Trump
does this stuff all the time where he'll
be like I want you Brave Patriot Hassan
to come to Mar-A-Lago and kiss me right
on the cheek and you know you sign up
here for a chance to get that
opportunity whatever right and it's like
I [ __ ] doubt he ever actually
he ever actually [ __ ] lets anybody
win those things
there's no way I've never heard from a
single person he never finishes the game
so I don't have to worry about it but
here it is
yes hi everyone this is Donald Trump
hopefully your favorite President of all
time better than Lincoln better than
Washington I I was so flattered I was
like why why why you got to throw shots
at Lincoln and Washington because it's
not even like a joke
he's right better than Lincoln better
than Washington he's looking good though
he's looking like he slimmed down a
little bit he's keeping it tight it's
hard to tell he's good at he wears
clothes really well yeah that hides you
know yeah it's that Donald J Trump brand
yes but okay so shout out I mean [ __ ]
L Lincoln L Washington yeah I agree uh
Trump never owned a SL well Lincoln I
don't think I've ever owned it yeah
either Trump didn't own a slave nor did
he free them
um
unclear what his opinion is on the
matter oh that's so funny with an
important announcement to make I'm doing
my first official Donald J Trump nft
collection right here and right now oh
you know that [ __ ] is AI digital trading
cards these cards feature some of the
really incredible okay you know what
bruh this is just embarrassing he said
wait wait what don't stop it I'm just
you got to take a look at this first I
mean
that looks like Joe Biden
he's yo they snuck a Joe Biden in there
yo that's just how dare you steal the
sweat Joe Biden swag
pertaining to my life and Mike this is
just pertaining to his life this is
horrible dog you've never you've never
had that physique like I'll tell you
what dude this looks like a SIMS
character like with his head on it why
is he why is he rizzed up like why does
he look like he's about to [ __ ] me you
know what I mean he's like yo what's up
[Music]
um
no no no no
raises the hot new word I've noticed as
a the Boomer I've noticed that is such
an old man way to say things yeah yeah
it's the amp boys that I know with it
what I'm saying I'm in touch I know
about the rising and the rizzlers yeah
there is Raz yeah it just means like you
know game you're kicking game I knew
that you didn't have to explain it to me
I don't know
anyway he looks like it's weird
he stands up he stands the [ __ ] up and
he looks like he's about to have sex at
the Opera that's what he looks like
I'm about to hear the fat lady sing and
then [ __ ] her
let's let's see what else is going on
here this is so this is like such a
budget you can collect it this is yeah
this is crazy I mean it looks like this
looks like one of those like fake
Insurance uh [ __ ] that you see you know
for for like really poor people so that
they can like drive a car but then the
insurance actually doesn't do anything
you can get yeah exactly did you know
you can get life insurance for three
dollars a year yeah
they take money from you
Parts just like a baseball card or other
collectible
best parts each card comes with an
automatic chance to win amazing prizes
but it's what was funny about this first
of all what the [ __ ] that's Nancy Pelosi
right
I see what you're saying but that's
definitely Nancy Pelosi this is also
definitely AI generated because you can
see the hands are [ __ ] up I think and
lastly
um I saw some like Bitcoin and crypto
enthusiasts that were like there you go
Trump actually like basically
acknowledged exactly what an nft is like
better than half of you guys who are
like maximalists it's just like a
baseball card it's like well no it's not
though it's not
because there's no physical aspect to
this well that's the least important
part about owning a material object I
would say no no no the real what is it
real yeah most most that's that's
optional existing is not an important
part most important part is the the
opportunity to be able to meet Donald
Trump for an hour at the golf course pay
a hundred dollars for a one in a hundred
thousand chance to golf with me for an
hour
it's what we have we're golf with you
and
you and your friends at one of my
beautiful golf courses and they are
beautiful I'm also doing Zoom calls a
one-on-one meeting autographing
memorabilia and so much more we're doing
a lot my official Trump digital trading
yeah you should be ashamed and
embarrassed that is stupid as hell no
that one's awesome when I need an iPad
yeah and he was signing an iPad I know
it's like like what are you autographing
that's his next nft
you don't get an autograph you get an
nft of the autograph it's more valuable
that way I just love that he's doing
Zoom calls I'll be zooming with you
folks for five minutes
Trump have it like that still I don't
even know this is kind of this is some
washed ass behavior I'm gonna be honest
Ron DeSantis is sitting in front of like
a [ __ ] villain in front of like this
like villain Megaplex with like screens
behind him saying he's gonna start
killing doctors that administered
covid-19 vaccines in Florida meanwhile
Donald Trump was like yes I will sign a
memorabilia you're right this is old
Trump ahead yeah what are you doing
Trump this this with the program this is
not rizz Behavior huh no he's not he
doesn't he doesn't have it like that
white ladies are no longer
white ladies are no longer trying to
throw it back for Donald Trump what's
the opposite of Riz
I don't know Dizz no there is nothing is
the opposite of rizz Liz
just the Elder is is the opposite of
risk
so much more we're doing a lot by doing
my official Trump digital trading cards
are 99 which doesn't sound like very
much for what you're getting buy one and
you will join a very it doesn't sound
like very much for what you're getting
which is nothing
exclusive Community it's my community
and I think it's something you're going
to like and you're going to like it a
lot they also make perfect gifts so you
can buy them with your credit card all
you need is an email address go to
collecttrumpcards.com and buy your Trump
digital trading cards right now before
they are all gone and they will be gone
it doesn't exist how do you run out of
digital cards because they artificially
like the artificial scarcity they just
make it seem like there's only like one
of ten but I doubt it I doubt that these
guys are hell yeah
hmm we're both the audit over here
artificial scarcity marvelous character
is only important if there's like a
resale Market I don't think anyone's
reselling this [ __ ] you know you're
holding on to that for dear life well
hold on here dude which one do you like
because I I'll I'll treat you right now
here hold on you're gonna buy me one
yeah Trump homelander is pretty hot do
you have um yeah gizio on this Dan how
do I take a screenshot
uh shift command four yeah shift yeah
command four four okay perfect so do you
like this one or some
I like that one okay wait what what are
you doing this is a legal Behavior this
is illegal stop cut away cut away cut
away stop it stop take it off the screen
stop it what are you doing answer me
snowflakes
what the [ __ ] I can't believe you
already did that that's literally dude
I don't want to be a conspiracy
no no
you're an accessory to this [ __ ] oh
we're going to jail ladies and gentlemen
we got him yeah so scarcity uh not
anymore
yeah [ __ ] that all right anyway L Trump
embarrassing cringe actually my fave
part though is his fans are super
unhappy about this which I don't get you
know she's trying to re she's trying to
Rizzy up his supporters okay you gotta
stop saying that didn't you it's over I
think officially once it reaches Ethan
the meme is is dead he didn't you're not
trying to Rizzy up his people oh God oh
my God
that sounds good to me
well here is uh
here's the the folder of all those of
the reactions of his peeps I know these
I mean I've seen these guys in my
replies I'm off I got banned on Twitter
but yeah man when all Patriots are
looking for is hope for the future of
our country and Trump Hypes up with a
big announcement then they drop a local
hey don't call it low quality did you
see that elephant
low quality nft collection video as the
announcement it just pushes people away
damn it's almost like he's a con artist
but no you ain't no no no no no no no
that's easy to do it's it's that easy to
dupe these [ __ ] I mean Elon is
doing it right now all he needs to do is
say woke mind virus and every
conservative will be like yes sir no
it's okay if you can like read my DMs uh
with every single person and and ban
whoever the [ __ ] you want willy-nilly
Elon literally is doing the thing that
conservatives claimed like liberal
Twitter was doing uh you know being
petty and like Banning people randomly
for their political beliefs or like you
know otherwise being like a nuisance
Elon is just straight up doing that
right now and everything's like well
actually there's a good reason for that
he didn't he's breaking two list dude
what are you talking about yeah he
literally just made a new rule so he
could ban the kid who was tracking his
flight yeah that was the biggest L ever
actually I've got a great bid on that
too because there's a subreddit that's
super popular now have you seen that no
what is it Trump flight tracker it's and
it's got like hundreds of thousands now
and I think I want to encourage everyone
to follow that because there's really
good information technically like yeah
all of that is public information anyway
it's just like it's FAA like you have to
admit
the irony is that I do think that
billionaires are going to get pissed off
about this now and then they're going to
make it so that like private jets are
not trackable or something and then 911
too baby
bro it's like you can afford security
stop whining just get just hire a
[ __ ] bodyguard freak use too many
kids right yeah you need a whole you'd
have to need like he's no longer the
richest man on the planet protect his
family kids loved Hitler yeah he already
has that he already has like private
mercenaries uh protecting him Jenna Ryan
said seriously that was the announcement
I thought he was taking down the Deep
state
mmm you were really far off you were
like really far off
no it's just it's just a grift to nft
Griff kidding the man has done
everything for our country oh she's
she's uh boot looking without his
efforts and sacrifice we would not be
where we are today yes he's made
mistakes but the things he's uncovered
are Priceless like what I'm buying an
nft collection hard truth time this is
not good we're facing a threat to
civilization from far left as Marxist
extremists teasing nft cars is a major
announcement is not the kind of fight
people wanna dude everyone's a liberal
this is like lib Behavior they're like
oh not a good look sweaty like that's
what they're doing to Donald Trump yeah
they literally are like you know how
like a lot of liberals have this
attitude where it's like the world is
[ __ ] ending and like there's some
truth to that right but like that
motivates every facet of their existence
and then like they get mad at innocuous
[ __ ] like your content consumption or
who you're [ __ ] following or whatever
and they're like the world is ending how
dare you talk about this right now
instead of something else like it's that
attitude on the right now they're like
pedophiles are running the government
why would you sell an nft while that's
happening you need be killing the
pedophiles that are running the
government instead not a good look
sweaty that's exactly the same [ __ ]
happening on the right and now they have
become liberals and therefore it's good
for America in a weird way because that
means that like you know they'll lose
because liberals love losing right we'll
find a way
but I'm pleased to announce that we are
dropping a leftovers nft collection uh
with us in uh astronaut uniform 100
bucks out the door
why does it say 45 on us
it's his age
well his says 45 too yeah what is why
does he say 45 on on our on our outfits
why is it oh because
I think we're not the 40-foot President
we just put our faces over Trump
that's double theft dude whatever what's
he gonna steal me for he stole it to
begin with loser
there's a chance to visit the 20 uh
billion dollar compound if you
buy one of our cards
that chance
if ten thousand people buy that card
today he'll make one million dollars
that's not what I was hoping for the
announcement was going to be as a matter
of fact I don't even think this is
worthy of the word announcement I'm
disappointed I was expecting to say he's
running for speaker or something
significant to do with our country shut
up and buy the nft like what would he do
as Speaker of the House like what do you
what do you think he's gonna do teach
Hunter Biden
but like but you can't but that's just
the Speaker of the House you can't do
that this is from our conservative which
is my favorite place Funko this is one
of the craziest things I've ever seen I
hope one of the cards is of trump
Jumping the Shark
okay wow you guys used to be a safe
space what happened
I think they're on the DeSantis train
because they're little [ __ ] dude
that's the they're disloyal the red is
all the [ __ ] turn code they're so
fake dude they're so spineless and fake
like Donald Trump is better than Ronald
Reagan he saved the country this anomaly
guy is just a straight anti-semite I
want to see what he has to say he always
has the worst opinions dude every time
like
every time I see his name on the
timeline it's like literally the dumbest
thing he's like he's got a good idea
about the Jews actually like okay bro we
get it he's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] he's
been acting like a big Pharma clown for
two years now why because he got the
vaccine but for some reason a lot of his
supporters wanted to Gaslight him lie
for him and let him fall this hard he's
been a garbage leader for two years now
running around the country selling his
glorious fauci back yeah they're mad at
him because he's giving everybody the
fauci ouchy
yeah my pronouns are impeach faucy
brother
my pronouns are arrest fouchy I think
ouchy
yeah but that was fun I thought you guys
would enjoy that
you know it's a big announcement
um this was interesting take I saw last
night on Twitter Eric Erickson okay dude
what's your middle name Eric stop well
there's W in there
Eric werrick Erickson W is just an e
turned on its side
what true yeah oh good call yeah you
need to tone it down so what is it a
conservative can wake up in the morning
and be denied service at a restaurant in
that afternoon in the afternoon that's
actually wait what that's right that's
actually happening what the [ __ ] that's
right read this one under it
pretty soon we're gonna have Democrats
only size posted at establishments the
Civil like the Civil Rights Movement
conservatives are
the new black people from the 1960s
that's right I'm tired of being bro I'm
I'm telling you like let me oppress you
dude like let me give you an actual
[ __ ] hard time so you guys don't have
to like fantasize about being oppressed
all the time oh they'll lose it no
that's what I mean like they're so
desperate to be oppressed like they're
just making [ __ ] up I've never they're
they're always like constantly looking
for new ways of Oppression new struggles
when there's none in their lives it's
indicative of that it's a lack of
struggle I like how they're like
I'm not even sure what they're referring
to that's this great struggle but they
immediately jump to warlock Jim Crow
blacks
I'm telling you man let me let me let me
add them you know well it's a win-win
it's a win-win like let me actually I
think we should actually unironically
cut legislation that says like if you're
a republican like you're not allowed to
eat at this establishment right you know
what I mean like make real mountains and
stuff
no I wouldn't go that far but
I don't know just like don't serve the
meals it like actually go to the
Applebee's CEO and say you know
Applebee's you have a profoundly
important uh role to play in the
conservative yeah uh lifestyle
you are going to allow uh liberals to
get five dollar jalapeno poppers but if
you're a conservative you have to pay
ten dollars oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up and
yeah only liberals get to berate the
waitresses and you have to show like a
conservative card or something yeah yeah
conservatives can only order salad yeah
salad only oh that's really good and of
course you're vegetarian mine would come
up with such an evil plot yeah Heather
was a vegetarian wasn't he I think he's
vegan even he was a vegan maybe I don't
know I'm not a study even Hitler is uh
Kanye West so I'm surprised Kanye hasn't
brought that up yet he was a woke King
uh was Hitler
he says he was a vegetarian all his life
oh okay right on he's like listen uh I
just I love animals and I don't want to
hurt them gas every Jew anyway uh yeah
cows are just sweet and uh we don't like
to harm the cows
that does kind of correspond to vegan
Behavior a little bit vegans love making
that vegans will be like we wouldn't
need a disabled person immediately they
would say uh yes I would
who are you talking about if they were
delicious yeah do you know who this guy
is a mega Pastor Trump called to Shane
Vaughn no check this out he's pissed
about the Brittany Greiner deal we
exchanged Brittany Greiner at WNBA
player for The Merchant of death AKA
he's not happy about this what the
Britney do
yeah it's brother Brittany look at the
Adam's apple darling oh he's he's doing
it he throws a basketball around and
kneels during the pledge of allegiance
to the flag amen refusing to pledge his
Allegiance does drugs hates America and
brother Brittany has a wife we can pause
it for a second right yo this is so
played out and I run with me
not all not all but like I gotta say
some here man yo I think maybe it's
because they're like off theater kids or
whatever and like whatever Backwater Poe
dunk a cousin [ __ ] town they come
from but every [ __ ] Southern
extremist Pastor I see is fruity as [ __ ]
dude I swear to God like what is that
what what the [ __ ] going on like I I
maybe like they because they love like
they have Pizzazz they want to be like
theater kids and that's why they become
pastors or some [ __ ] but like that dude
is like I I can I can you know I see it
I've been saying that and people get mad
at me when I say that but you're right
because it's not just homophobia is is
not coming exclusively from you know gay
people they know that but of course or
in the Clouds of gay people but like
repressed homosexuality definitely is a
thing but amongst other pastors it feels
like how can you how can you hate gay
people so much and they consume so much
of your mind and you don't at least have
thought a one time at least about
touching or tasting a dick like it's
like you know it's like you take Michael
Jackson for example and not to compare
them but you go you ask yourself okay
people say Michael Jackson's innocent
right so you say Okay Michael Jackson
slept in a bed with how many kids how
many times and you're telling me he
didn't flick their dick once at least oh
dude why are we talking about but I'm
just saying like you got to play the oh
my God
you gotta play the odds with Michael are
you saying anything I'm saying that
these guys thinking about gay people all
[ __ ] die brother yeah I mean I think
that this guy this guy's a little zesty
okay that's all I'm saying he's giving
he's giving 21 can you do something for
me okay yeah yeah
that's right that's right brother
Brittany has a wife that sounds fine you
know what I mean that's Traditional
Values brother no he's just he's like
misgendering a assist uh you know a CIS
woman because
she's uh not subscribing the traditional
standards because she's too tall I guess
but he says she's a man yeah then he
criticized this man for having a wife
like hello The Merchant of death is the
Bill Gates of arms dealing it's not true
our American
fake pseudo government
felt that we could afford to let The
Merchant of death go that's all Putin
wanted was The Merchant of death that
was our Ace of Spades darling
if you want to get good boy darling come
on
you know what I'm saying darling he's
yeah he's giving he's given zest
I learned yesterday that poppers
loosened the butthole during gay sex
wait who told you that stavi yeah super
mega taught me that I didn't know that
yeah I did it I did some poppers with
them oh for real yeah how was it
um my butthole did not feel loose
yeah it was you trying to insert
something yeah it was really hard to
take both of them at the same time still
okay well that is for those of you who
don't know I thought it was a podcast
it's just two dudes having gay sex right
and um you know when I went on I'm
thinking like oh it's gonna be a podcast
nope just gay sex yeah no it's weird but
that sounds nice
gay yeah
uh [ __ ] yeah so poppers apparently back
brother Brittany
then why don't you go find a Russian
prostitute that we've got in jail and
give her back in exchange for brother
Brittany because their value is about
the same what
you see ah Professor Toto says the quiet
part out loud your professor Toto you're
named after the little dainty cute
little dog from Alice in wonder calls
himself Professor Toto uh
I can't even I I he's just he's cute he
is cute I like his style he's a little
portly and I like that
um
anyway okay you see ah Professor Toto
says the quiet part out loud I say what
you've been thinking that I ain't never
had thoughts like you brother
um yeah I love that he's like The
Merchant of death if he heard what the
merchant had to say about like the 72
genders or whatever he probably love it
though he's like thank God a brave
Patriot was released I'll take it back
brother you hate the trans just like I
do yeah I'm surprised he even like
criticized him I thought he'd be down
with him yeah
um let's see oh uh Marjorie Taylor girl
it's so stupid I like Titan green is the
best yeah but she actually has um
an interesting shopping list at Target
and CVS uh you guys will notice
take a listen
absolutely not you know what's funny
about this is like it's always a silver
board it's like Jordan Peterson being
like I can't find good child pornography
nowadays smiley face smiley
I don't think we ever showed that one
why did you say that what is wrong with
you I mean I think maybe she's confusing
with Amazon
because you sure can on Amazon brother I
put like what's up like what I she's
like man I've been a targeted CVS never
seen a butt plug or a dildo I mean it
could it could have helped in a pinch
you know what I mean sometimes
okay sometimes your your vibrator runs
out of power and like you know it's you
you lost the [ __ ] charger you know
just pop on over to the Target
I've nodded like a big veiny [ __ ] but
like um personal massager type oh yeah
actually they do have uh they do have
[ __ ] rings at Target yeah 100 I don't
believe that yeah no they do
yeah yeah they always but it's dinky
it's not good oh it's like a condom
thing yeah it goes yeah if you go to the
if you go to the condoms like sexual
Wellness section they they do have like
[ __ ] rings sometimes but it's like not a
good one it's not not recommended it's
not like like they have dildos and
vibrators but it's not like a vibrator
you think
it's like a personal massage like a
massage no no they sell they sell
vibrators
back massage right it doesn't look like
like I said a big vein looks like a
[ __ ] space but the Cocker I'm talking
about is like specifically if you go to
the sexual Wellness like you know the
condom section they have like one of
those Rinky Dink like not even silicone
uh [ __ ] rings that have a vibrator
attached to it yeah but it's not very
good
you've tried it yeah yeah yeah I just
remembered so Marjorie she's not very
girthy she's uh she's she's into that
stuff huh oh for sure
with the CrossFit instructor right
that's why and to be honest You Can Tell
She's Freaky and I don't mean to judge
but you could tell she's she's like
crazy yeah
yeah you know what I mean like she got
that and and I I listen I'm just saying
and there's you know how do I I gotta
I gotta do a thousand uh disclaimers
here so what do you mean there's nothing
wrong oh your sex shame and your day
clubs aren't extreme whatever dude she's
marginal entirely green she eats [ __ ]
babies who cares what she puts in her
ass
yeah
anything she can do in reach she
probably shows up her ass
I wanted to get specific with it like
just lean into it be like you know you
know you can get booty boot camp at one
of these places now you go to Target
they're selling it to you I tried it
okay first I tried it with the six
incher and just like go further into it
and it's just like describing you and I
didn't want to do it folks I didn't want
to do it that's why my divorce happened
she's the first victim of Divorce Court
on the female side I love that
my friends did you know they got them
nice butt plugs at Target that vibrate
when your partner has an app on their
phone
it's disgusting I got oh and then she's
like oh yeah I hate it I hate one of
them things where like you know you put
it inside of you and it lights up when
your partner's tapping on it on their
phone I got a butt plug so bright my
eyeballs shine
laughs
you know I don't even know how we got
here
they called him bad dragons folks it's
like a it's like an alien penis with
like multiple heads on it it's
disgusting and they're way too big by
the way yeah I hate it I hate it so much
way too big yeah I prefer the horse ones
them's as big but not too big
so Jordan Peterson who is now of course
boot looking for uh Elon Musk no
yes you are I think if I had to throw
the disclaimer up with this one when
we're when we're covering it because
it's crazy yeah we just we've disavowed
this one Jordan
um yes this uh this one was not a banger
okay
Robert Reich said Elon Musk is enable us
to turn this website into a torn of ad
hominem attacks lies floated as jokes
and blatant misinformation
Jordan Peterson quoted it and said it's
getting just impossible to find child
porn dot dot dot smiley face it's like
this implies that you have looked my man
you have tried desperately to find it
like in the past and easily accessed it
and like now it's getting harder like
dude I have never seen child porn on
Twitter and I've never tried it I don't
understand like I I don't know how the
[ __ ] you even find this [ __ ] and I feel
like it says more about you if you know
how to access child porn
yeah how do you gauge that based on
before when you were finding it and now
your favorite accounts are banned like
what I I actually don't understand oh
you got them good at Los Angeles true do
you think he's in Canada though but we
can put a no fly on him no yeah dude
seize his [ __ ] hard drives what's
going on dude
Pierce in a while let's see here I
haven't I had to download what's the
name of the of the browser where you can
tour I had to I had to download tor
Define my kitty porn I usually go to
Kitty my favorite Kitty I'm [ __ ] up
my accent
I go and find my kitty porn but counts
on Twitter I think Kermit the Frog but
then there you go
I had to download tor it's hard we are
definitely demonetized it's hard to find
it on tour you gotta find look all kind
of find a website URL no way Susan's
letting this slide Ethan what are you
doing it's hard but I found one that's
Auschwitz it was basically Auschwitz
for my penis
[Music]
gassed it all night
[Laughter]
oh my God it's my struggle there it is
everyone is always talking about theirs
but my struggle is not being able to
find easily accessible CP on Twitter
I'm gutted I'm absolutely in shambles
Elon sex bring back the child
pornography on Twitter okay please okay
let's move on
all right where would we be without
child pornography on Twitter
I want to see her bombing I I didn't
actually get to watch this part it's
pretty much at the end okay very sorry
I apologize
no but this is a statement yeah oh no
you suck
like that group of individuals has never
laughed a day in their lives but like it
doesn't take much for them to clap for
you at least you know what I mean all
you need to say is like Nancy Pelosi is
a Russian spy and then everyone will be
uh she's a communist
um and and even then like you lost that
crowd that's crazy they're there to like
literally clap for you in Applause
breaks all right
yeah
they're just getting increasingly
unhinged like Ben Shapiro did a
40-minute rant on like gay marriage
being a bad thing
slippery slope to like people marrying
dogs bro that's like come on you got to
move off that by now nobody they I'm
saying like they're getting increasingly
unhinged like they're trying to say like
oh gay marriage hypothetically if gay
marriage is allowed and codified by the
government well then they're coming for
you they want to groom your children
it's like what that doesn't even make
any literally no thread there that
connects there yeah but so you're
probably speaking about the marriage
respect for marriage act that was
recently signed actually bipartisan I
was happy to see yeah a lot of
Republicans except for Mitch McConnell
he was like I hate my interracial
marriage that I'm in well I I and I
thought I could stop it from going
forward I I just don't want to make a
decision for for all the people of
America but uh abortion should should
definitely be legal bro you're literally
a politician like that's your job
so Biden signed it in which is awesome
actually in 2008 Biden apparently says
he doesn't support gay marriage so God
bless we come a long way but no he's
just listen he learns and he changed
he did it's fine he that's growth sweaty
that's what he demonstrated okay that's
the way they're talking about it like
this man is not a [ __ ] political
demon like of course back then it was
not even though it was fashionable
Democrats are cowardly and 100 did not
want to fight for it because they never
wanted they never wanna yeah exactly
they never want to take a step in the
right direction because they're
unprincipled but Ben does this on the
other side where he will act like like
he did in 2019 when he was on The Joe
Rogan Experience I covered this on my
show yesterday he was saying like I'm
not a Theocratic fascist so I don't have
a problem with gay marriage from a legal
standpoint but now he's like all about
having a problem with gay marriage Bella
signed yeah because because you know 6-3
Supreme Court let's go yeah so the right
wing reaction to this bipartisan bill
they basically said
that they will not discriminate against
um gay couples or I guess interracial
couples too which is so interesting that
that actually need to be said but no
they did that I mean the Republicans are
right when they say that like they add
that on specifically because well the
main reason is because
um you know uh which I forget which
Justice it was that said that uh
obergefell is up for
uh is is up for discussion
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
so and also interracial marriage as well
Loving Virginia uh under that same
privacy uh like say under under the same
interpretation of like privacy uh
established by the Constitution so
that's the reason why they did this it's
symbolic for the most part but
um you know conservatives love just
saying like anything that's Pro queer
automatically is is grooming and and you
know pedophilia while simultaneously you
know are are hyping up rumors and
pedophiles
um
by the way check out this Photoshop
that's awesome
here is Tucker saying Biden's passing
the marriage equality Act is basically
talk she's trying to promote drag shows
uh to distract from other issues it's an
interesting insight people talk about
stuff like this particularly when it's
not strictly speaking relevant because
they don't want to talk about other
things and that makes it even more
interesting that Joe Biden's Handler 16
years later are telling him to talk
about gay marriage and drag shows
anything to distract you and in fact
that was an interesting insight
is he talking interactions
no
um I think they're like they're playing
fast and loose right like on the one
hand I think he brought up
he did bring up the the uh gay nightclub
that was shot oh there he
and I think like because Republican
commentators have like completely given
up the game and like openly stated their
desire to murder gay people in their uh
you know places of comfort
he's basically saying like oh no the the
you know the place got shot up because
there was a drag show and when Joe Biden
brings up the the nightclub that was
shot up he's actually bringing up drag
shows he's the you know
man can you believe God look at her she
is just a Titan
uh she says gay marriage is not anywhere
under attack in this country
in fact The Marriage Act is a trick to
turn gay community
against the Republican Party
oh
that's interesting
guys what it really is is it's another
Democrat trick to using campaign ads
that's all this is because they know for
a fact that gay marriage is not issue in
the background it sure is oh Jesus
that's surprised that I like oh God
that's I mean she's already so [ __ ]
gross let me sniff that Marjorie
margarine I need that used tissue please
oh
tree and no one's trying to take it away
from them the whole purpose of that bill
is an attack on Christians and it's an
attack on religious freedom that's
exactly what that bill is about it and
it's and it will be used against
Republicans in campaign ads of oh they
voted against gay marriage then why did
they vote again why did you vote against
that cool was it easy for everyone like
why why did you do that then
like it was so simple then why did you
do it just you should have just voted
for it then you [ __ ] dumbass right
that's fair but at the same time it's an
attack on Christians somehow
you know yeah I just they're so annoying
still not [ __ ] up still not sure about
that one so they're you they're going to
try to use the gay community to turn
them against uh the Republican party
because guess what they're so important
LGBT
um and well go with LGB I don't know
about the t's and the cues but I like
she's halfway there to respecting yeah I
don't know about it I'll go all right
you convinced me on the lblb part that
you know but all the t's and q's I'm
ready for all that she is British coded
with how ugly she is so it's no wonder
that she posted up with the [ __ ] LGB
over there
I want to call her ugly but if anyone
deserves to be called ugly well it's her
her soul or the inside right not her
face her body no she looks like a
[ __ ] Titan what are you gonna tell me
like oh man giving you enough Marjorie
Taylor green might not hear your words
about how she looks like a [ __ ] Titan
from Attack on Titan but my friend who
does look like a Titan will is that what
you're gonna say she is uniquely ugly
okay none of you look like her well no
she's a [ __ ] beast she's a disgusting
her soul her soul is ugly she's a
[ __ ] vile freak of a person I agree I
mean she is just like burned and tar and
fat her soul
She's a pig her soul is there a butt
coming at the end of this no my point no
I'm just trying to get away with calling
her an ugly [ __ ] pig
the way I see it like the way I see it I
don't know why people act like this
isn't the case but like yeah I mean sure
there are people who don't have the best
physical qualities or whatever but like
their personalities are wonderful and
you don't consider them to be ugly at
all like Adam Driver
[Music]
yeah
watch your mouth you've seen him
shirtless watch your [ __ ] mouth 20
people why like that why are you why are
you coming for that dude
with this about
but no but she's a [ __ ] piggy she's a
piggy out to Roots come on piggy her
soul yes yes I won't get in the mud and
wrestle with that ugly [ __ ] piggy ass
you should be ashamed of yourself her
insides are so awful they just like
seeped out to the outside right is what
I mean no she's what she is wild though
in all seriousness inside and out and
well inside of her soul and outside of
her soul most of them many of them vote
Republican and the devil shut up dummy
you're not even worth the [ __ ] effort
stupid ass big ass [ __ ] pig-faced
soul
anyway that's MTG
whatever [ __ ] all these people you know
what I mean there's Hannity and Ingram
but who cares [ __ ] losers we get it
you don't like gay people how many times
you didn't say it
well the LGB is fine not the tea though
I love that
Q order
it's the same [ __ ] always it's just like
they are trying to Teeter along the
boundaries of what is considered
acceptable uh Hey levels of hatred
that's what it is
like just like they used to say Judea
Christian values and then Marjorie
Taylor green dropped the judeo pretty
quick she was like this a Christian
Nation actually we just said judeo
because I
because and I was afraid but then I
found out when I went to the Holocaust
Museum they told me they don't have the
lasers so I'll just say it is a
Christian Nation now I'm no longer
afraid yeah maybe that's why she was
saying Judea Christian okay so let's
talk about
um
Elon Musk Banning this kid who's been
tracking his
private jet and then we'll get into our
uh how to debate year
Maga family
um so free speech absolutist Elon Musk
who banned me by the way and I am still
banned well yeah you did violate the law
yeah I did steal someone's identity no
you violated the law by offending Elon
Musk that's true that is the law that is
the law of the land now Ethan
yes so check this out he I remember he
tweeted this he says and he even [ __ ]
made a point of saying this my
commitment to free speech extends even
to not Banning the account following my
plane even though that is a direct
personal safety risk well that's big of
him yeah they don't want to know how
many times Kimball musk is like flying
to [ __ ] uh you know every house that
Jeffrey Epstein ever lived in you know
what I mean like they just don't want
that out there that's probably why he's
upset it does make me think he's flying
to Shady spots of course he's flying to
shitty spots no it's also because like
Elon Musk is supposedly Mr Green right
Mr Green energy right and like we all
know private jets are massive consumers
massive carbon polluters and he probably
doesn't want people to know that he's
flying from [ __ ] Dallas to Los
Angeles like three times a week back and
forth that's six goddamn trips is a nine
minute [ __ ] flight and that's
precisely the reason why he's like uh
you know upset on that front too
yeah so but that's that's a big
Proclamation he made um by the way if
you go down
so Elon jet oh well here we'll get to
that you know yeah so
basically there's this kid
quite Infamous he made a Tracker that
follows Elon Musk private jet Elon Musk
actually offered to buy it from him for
those for the record uh yeah he tried to
silence the account for five thousand
dollars this stuff is is readily
available you can find Elon musk's
flights still regardless of whether it's
on Twitter or not because it is uh it's
a FAA protocol every flight that flies
has to be tracked and it is being
tracked in real time all the time this
is commercial flights this is private
flights as well okay we live in a
post-911 world every flight that we know
is out there you can track with the
exception of I think Janus that's the
one Janice air is that what it's called
I forget the the one the little red
plane that goes to area 51. oh I see
um but and maybe some other ones but
um you know that's all that this bot was
doing was and and there's plenty of bots
that do this on Twitter there was one
that was tracking the Russian oligarch
Jets as a matter of fact and and Elon
literally first he took down Jack
Sweeney's uh you know Elon jet account
which was tracking elon's private jet
then he took down the SpaceX jet account
which was the corporate jet account that
was tracking SpaceX corporate jet uh
flights then he took down Jack Sweeney's
account his personal account okay and he
banned links to this kid's uh Instagram
and [ __ ] like yeah he banned links to
his Instagram that has that and and he
he hit it with the CP uh marker
basically like when you can't even DM it
to someone like it's the highest level
it is literally the highest level of of
uh security for for a particular
um a a particular link yeah so
um you couldn't even DM it to one
another if you wanted like he's so
openly just
moderating Twitter
on his own whims about what offends him
personally it's like actually [ __ ]
insane and by the way so he went from
he went from uh I will not even ban this
person I'm such a free speech absolute
it's too real-time posting of someone
else's location violates doxing policy
but delayed posting of locations are
okay and by the way he got corrected or
amended publishing flight records is
protected under the First Amendment what
is going on there I thought he was the
first amendment absolutist there's even
poor president on this yeah no it's it's
uh it's wild that he's like I mean he's
a billionaire he could change the law as
well you know what I mean and he
probably will uh eventually to make it
so that like private jets can no longer
be trackable or something
um
but uh that account is still up on other
social medias
however
um he completely wiped it off the
website then unbanned the the Jack
Sweeney's personal account
then re-band it then openly admitted
that it was actually a personal matter
for him said that he was going to sue
Jack Sweeney and claimed that he was
yeah he said there's a lawsuit coming
first I missed that lawsuit coming from
against this poor kid yeah it was in one
of his replies because he said that like
little X was uh was stalked by yeah uh a
a stalker whose car was you know traced
and then the guy stopped the car and
jumped on the hood of the car that his
his son was in I think he was saying
he'd take legal action against it and
he's saying that he's no he's not saying
he's taking legal action against the
soccer he's saying he's taking legal
action against Jack Sweeney I don't
think that's what he said no that's here
let's see I'm seeing articles that he is
yeah oh my God you are such a loser yeah
he said last night car carrying Little X
in La was followed by crazy stalker
thinking it was me who later blocked car
from moving and climbed on the hood
legal action is being taken against
Sweeney and organizations who supported
harm to my family bro you for all I know
[ __ ] hired that dude so you could
[ __ ] no no no I think like I think that
as a billionaire I've heard this from I
mean I'll just say it I've heard this
from Grimes like personally that a lot
of people stalk her and her child yeah
and and Elon Musk as well of course he's
a [ __ ] billionaire like I got
stalkers [ __ ] and I you know
what I mean and I'm nope it's like dude
you want to be this most famous man in
the world so desperately of course
there's gonna be people [ __ ] and
that's still completely unacceptable of
course like that that [ __ ] is insane uh
luckily Elon Musk also has you know
gorillions of [ __ ] dollars and
therefore is capable of hiring like
security teams for himself that still
doesn't make it justifiable but this has
nothing to do with your [ __ ] private
jet uh flights whatever I mean yeah
Twitter's not supposed to be like your
PR your little private play Space where
you can just well apparently it is now I
mean it is but at least people should
acknowledge what a petty little [ __ ]
[ __ ] boy he is and that he's is really
just moderating it on a whim based on
his own yeah and and to make that grand
proclamation of I will not even ban this
dude and then he's like I'm suing him
and I banned all of his accounts and I
hate his guts
yeah um he also he also wrote this
policy specifically in a way that like I
mean they did this so haphazardly they
literally did this last second and he
wrote this [ __ ] policy in a way where
basically like Libs of tick tock is fine
if she docks his like queer teenagers or
queer professors or whatever right but
like people that would then you know
post lives of tick tocks information
will go uh will will no longer be able
to you know be on uh Twitter people
can um you know go to an event go to
like a drag uh you know go to Drag
Brunch or whatever and you know with
weapons and film everyone that's there
but if you actually uh film the person
with a gun then you know you're
if you're at the drag launch and or Drag
Brunch and you're filming the people
that are there you're doxing them hmm
by the way here's Twitter safety post
which I think Elon wrote he's just
logged into his Alt
we've updated our private information
policy prohibiting sharing someone
else's live location
when someone shares an individual's live
location on Twitter there is an
increased risk of physical harm I mean
you're talking about yourself but okay
not for normal people no there is I mean
he's right about that like I mean that's
understandable okay but
um but the the idiocy was from all the
Elon dick writers and my [ __ ]
mentions being like well what if someone
like you know your house records are
public like what if someone docks you
I'm like okay first of all Welcome to My
Life secondly secondly like there's a
difference between Jet flight patterns
and your [ __ ] home that you live in
okay or the car that you're driving in
why because the car is easily accessible
your home is easily accessible with but
your flight patterns are are still
there's like a level of protection that
you have because not everybody has a
[ __ ] you know anti-aircraft missile
system like how are they gonna [ __ ]
intercept your flight this is an
interesting question under the updated
policy would learn bobert have been
suspended for live tweeting Nancy
Pelosi's whereabouts during the January
Insurrection oh no
oh there this this one this speaker has
been removed from the chamber
I guess maybe about who gives a [ __ ] but
yeah I mean it's not no surprise that
elon's a little [ __ ] boy [ __ ]
sensitive little piggy oh come on Piggy
yeah it was just
it was definitely it was definitely like
a petty move it's so obvious it's so
transparent it's so gross and
um I don't fault Elon for doing that
like his abusive power is a given right
he of course he was gonna do that he's
like a [ __ ] real life villain what I
do hate is all the dumbass like
peasant-brained idiots that are
defending his his like very clear abuse
of power right like there should be
something
intrinsic to The Human Condition that
goes you know what this guy is abusing
his authority in like a very obvious way
yeah you feel that way when a bouncer
doesn't let you into a club you feel
that way when a manager like enforces
their authority over you and and forces
you to do the day shift when you know
you have something going on in the
family and you can't work that day but
for some weird reason people cannot uh
feel that way when it's like someone
that they've deified because they're a
billionaire and they are powerful in
that position and every move that they
make is like the adequate one he's he's
playing 5D chess all the time it's like
no man he's not he's just like making
[ __ ] up as he goes along but you're too
stupid to [ __ ] see it um
yeah well guys if you're passionate
about this
there's a subreddit called Elon jet
tracker and uh it's become quite popular
um
I just like to know uh you know from 12
hours ago
this is all data from elon's jet so it's
okay to share
Epstein's
oh that's funny keep it to you that's a
12 trips to this location no that's not
real you can't actually land on Epstein
Island it's too small to land on little
St James okay you know a lot about
Epstein's Island
are you kidding me I did like an eight
hour I once uploaded an eight hour video
on Jeffrey Epstein to YouTube and my
channel was blacklisted
like I am very very uh in tune with the
Jeffrey Epstein Saga
this is but yeah this this is awesome
um so in tune that I know Elon mus
brother Kimball musk actually partied
with Jeffrey Epstein and was uh making a
lot of trips to the Jeffrey Epstein
compound in New York Kimball musk
um maybe people should start asking
questions about what Kimball has been up
to where's Kimball's lap where's Kimball
here I want some anyway here's his Jet
right now by the way if anyone's
wondering let's see where is it I can't
I guess it's loading let's see
yeah we know we know I [ __ ] that one
is so cringy wait where's the jet
um I think he he might have like figured
out a way to private it uh like
wait how because he was trying to do
that for so long now I think he
originally there's like a couple
different ways you can do it it's tote
we're dark
he's gone dark yeah
or he's right here and it hasn't loaded
is it possible that he's in
einfield
uh
it seems unlikely is it possible he is
on the corner of stop
let's see
we found him folks he's on the corner of
einfield and Lake Court Vale what the
[ __ ] he also like took a photo of
someone
and posted it under that anyone
recognize this person in her car what
the [ __ ] is that that's the person who
um
that's the stalker that's insane
theoretic what's that guy doing yeah you
know by the way um bonus
Elon Musk has sold 3.6 billion in Tesla
stock
just yesterday or the day before yeah so
cashing out
Tesla is also down 60 this year so we
wish him the best we love Elon Musk we
kid Elon Musk
[Applause]
so guys as you know we all coming
together during the holidays
and we all got uncles and
God forbid brothers sisters parents
who um they're just
watch Fox News too much you know
or Ben Shapiro
or Alex Jones or
the list goes on
and so you're gonna have to sit at a
table
share some ham
sometimes the conversation gets
political so we're going to do a little
cosplay here in the tradition of the
holidays I will be playing
Uncle Nathaniel Clansman I watch Fox
News and I love Tucker Carlson
and Sean Hannity
they are my favorites I get all my news
but I got this live nephew he's a
[ __ ] lib
I hate him I'll poison his gravy
so
let's start do we have a stinger or
something to get in there
no okay all right okay great
all right here we go guys
let me make sure my hat's on right
can I get into character yeah
do you have the Stinger from last year
yeah hit me something all right we gotta
say I gotta transform
yeah oh what there is that's the one
from that's the one from last show me
whatever it was still good yeah it's
still good what happened it's still good
because it was Thanksgiving theme but
you know
why is it Thanksgiving to you because it
was Thanksgiving last year I know but
that's not Thanksgiving the images I
guess it could just use a dinner you're
right you're right dinner's dinner
so I've been thinking
y'all really Biden's been destroying
this great country inflation is through
the roof they teaching our Youngs to be
homosexuals
the gays in preschool
there's a God dang out of control
epidemic woke mind virus poisoning our
kids and turning them into communist
Nazis
what we what we gonna do about it okay
Uncle Nathaniel we're we're putting you
in the old folks home next year that's
what we're gonna do about it
um okay vote from there whenever
whenever whenever Uncle Nathaniel brings
up inflation one of the things you can
immediately bring up is the fact that uh
you know Republicans have actually
brought zero to the table as far as
combating inflation now the difference
is for the fine people that actually is
a cause for inflation that's an
inflationary move so you would have
increased taxes to to uh potentially uh
stop inflation what are you some kind of
Economist I missed the chapter where you
got a degree the only the the there are
multiple methods of dealing with
inflation one uh there is Congressional
methods you can deal with inflation uh
you know taxes increasing taxes is one
of the ways that you can do it but
unfortunately we only use the fed and
there and that is uh a separate body and
it doesn't require congressional action
as a and Congress is unfortunately
I lost his damn uh talking all this
Jibber Jabber I just like Trump and he
gonna get it done by them destroying
this country well Trump actually pumped
uh way more money into the economy than
anyone else did in the beginning of the
pandemic which uh you know had no that
was a holdover from Obama
who's the economy that's not that's not
a holdover it was passed over the bad
economy was passed to him by Obama
the economy was actually very good uh
when it passed over to Donald Trump well
I don't know about all that as far as
the young ones being taught
homosexuality uh that's not a real thing
either every single instance of like
kitty litter boxes and schools or you
know teachers teaching about like anal
sex to children they're all almost
always entirely false uh I seen on Joe
Rogan he said yeah Joe Rogan Joe Rogan's
a good man Joe Rogan is an idiot Joe
Rogan is a wise and good man Joe Rogan
is a self not handle disparagement
against that good man Joe Rogan is a
self-admitted idiot and an ape uh Joe
Rogan said he's seen it a friend has
seen a kitty box Joe Rogan also openly
admitted it Joe Rogan also openly
admitted that that story was false
I ain't seen that
well he did
and then you can find the video if you
want
um I don't know about all right what
else you got Uncle Nathan I thought you
know Joe Biden he's trying to destroy
marriage for good Christians you know he
taught us with this respect for Marriage
Act the gays wait the gays weren't
having no problems and why they got to
make it our problem with respect the gay
marriage they're trying to destroy
Christianity I'll tell you what my they
gonna cause a flood like we've never
seen yeah
these are not common curveballs
Nathaniel also Uncle Nathaniel come in
Black I don't know how to I don't know
how to debauchery leaves the flood you
know how it works the only real floods
that are happening are happening is a
consequence of climate change well
that's what's happening
oh wow
that's a bunch of gym or Jamba as far as
yeah as far as uh you know gay gay
people causing floods I can't speak on
that but respect for marriage is you
know codified as a consequence of just
Clarence Thomas's uh opinion uh in the
aftermath of the abortion ban or the the
abortion decision where it felt like the
6-3 Supreme Court that is majority
conservative was threatening potentially
interracial marriage and gay marriage
and uh for that reason Congress decided
to codify it which was a good move
ultimately I just think it's a way it's
nothing to you you know at all if you
hate the gays to get two and we gotta
what cater to them gays if it's not that
big of a deal then why are you that
upset about it also as far as you know
if you hate the gays don't you want them
to also get divorced and be victims of
Divorce Court like you Uncle Nathaniel
the evil the divorce court are coming to
the Gaze as well I've only been divorced
twice and you know my last wife Vicky
was a [ __ ] that's what I'm saying now
now now uh the the gay communities can
also be impacted in a similar capacity I
don't know about all that are the Perils
of Divorce Court only the man and women
here let me see this Joe Rogan talk
about them Kitty Lookers and spoke about
the crazy rumor on his podcast my friend
his wife is a school teacher see that's
it I heard him say it she is weird like
an urban legend I fed into that I don't
think they actually did it it doesn't
seems
now listen what he said boy you ain't
listening
stopping other influentials
he just said I don't think he's covering
the bases so he can't get mobbed by
liberals there's a there's a chance that
a meteor could strike every school too
but you know he didn't say it did but
it's not happening he didn't say that
hessen he did say it he said I don't
think it happened
and then he went did you not see he did
not win there's no wing god damn it
there was no wings hey Uncle Nathaniel
you're on the TV hey look at me boy
all right what else
what else
uh we already covered The Joe Rogan
thing so you can see that one yeah
that's true we did cover that on there
y'all heard about this critical race
Theory I just don't think our kids need
to be learned about this nonsense ain't
nothing racist about our country I don't
see no slaves what do you think critical
race theory is it means that white
people need to feel guilty about
everything
white people
they the root of all the evil that's not
what critical I don't know about you but
I'm my mom a nice woman she connect me
but I just take care of all my man she
ain't never said nothing about some
black folk
that's not what critical race theory is
and that is not being taught in schools
regardless but if you think that's not
what I heard if you think the critical
race theory is about like instilling
white guilt in the population yeah
that's it you could you could learn
about what uh is actually being
advocated or uh being advocated against
being taught in schools which is the
genuine devastating contemporary impacts
of Shadow slavery Shadow one and uh the
the reality that systemic racism exists
within our criminal systems and that
racism is just a conspiracy I tell you
man I look around ain't no slaves black
people they got a good today boy they
gotta do they got it better than me they
don't uh there are disparities that
still exist in society for black people
Kenny he couldn't get into no goddamn
school and you talk to me about black
people got hard now ain't no affirmative
action for the child I couldn't get into
school because because he was
homeschooled by you Uncle Nathaniel
that's why he couldn't get into school
well I don't trust the institutions but
I don't know how you know that you don't
even know what two plus two is
you know one plus one is it's a man and
a woman
yeah exactly that's why no wonder your
kid getting into school
um but as far as as far as immigration
goes as far as systemic racism goes
there's either external factors or
internal factors as to why black people
is a whole underperformed uh regardless
of their socioeconomic status when
compared to other people of similar
statuses like a rich black person or a
rich black family and a rich white
family under similar conditions uh will
will often yield uh worse results for
the black family now either you believe
that this is a consequence of external
conditions which then you would have to
admit is systemic racism or you think
it's internal conditions intrinsic
factors and then you would have to you
okay well then that's racist because you
think backwards inherently okay where
are these racist because all I see is
the black on black people they they out
there doing crime and all know
black on black crime rates are identical
to white on white crime rates because
crime is conducted within either the
family or in the neighborhoods that
people live in and Americans very
segregated didn't want to live a life of
crime then why don't they move out the
poor neighborhoods
well they were forced into living in
poor neighborhoods you live in a poor
neighborhood why can't you live in
Beverly Hills well ain't no blacks
around here well I mean but you're still
living in a poor neighborhood Uncle
Nathaniel you need his four is there
because it's hard it's hard to move out
of that neighborhood right
I don't know
okay what else we gotta take the L on
that one
all right he got me there
I'll admit
yeah but I'll tell you man
immigration is ruining this good old
country man they send in all the worst
over them rapists crime drug dealers
they come here for the green card
and they skip the line
I don't like the Mexicans I don't like
them okay
I tell you they ruining all of our
everything immigration or immigrants uh
whether undocumented or documented
immigrants skin is dark I don't like
them okay well that's pretty racist but
it is what it is
um immigration is not a contributing
factor to a crime rate that is
supposedly skyrocketing which is not
even happening crime is not on the up uh
in comparison to year over year
considerations if you look back into the
90s crime is at an all-time low this is
almost like a global uh reality for
every other country as well as the
United States of America when I put on
the local news and fox all I see is
violent crimes here because just like
the liberal media is brainwashing
everybody uh so it was the conservative
Media Fox News is the most popular media
Network on the in in the United States
and they're brainwashing you into
thinking that crime is happening in
every corner in big cities when that is
not the case I never even I wouldn't go
to
that city is dangerous there's a horns
net and a milk and a Cowboys titty okay
well let me ask you this then you think
these Liberals are they're soy right
they're scared they're fearful
what soy soy like gay what and scared I
ain't never I need to medigate gaze of
things okay but like Liberals are
they're [ __ ] right yeah they're
[ __ ] okay then are you telling me
that like libtar is the living of these
big cities libtards can live in these
big cities but you can't because you're
afraid of the big city
hmm Howard I can't wear no gun how are
these softies how are these softies able
to live in these like crime ridden
cities while still maintaining their
softy status without even a gun they
scared they stay in the apartments and
do all that Postmates business oh okay I
went there and I can't even get strapped
with a weapon I've been overrun by the
homeless yeah yeah homelessness is a
consequence of of market conditions
specifically the housing market big real
estate developers are making it so that
uh it's virtually impossible they just
don't want to work that's not true as a
matter of fact plenty of homeless people
do continue to try and work as best as
they possibly can but unfortunately when
you don't have a zip code when you don't
have a you know a mailbox when you don't
have uh you know working a working
sewage system they can take advantage of
it becomes yeah
I seen my uncle man my my cousin Jeffrey
living on the street he [ __ ] right there
in the [ __ ] Street yeah that's
because there's no public bathrooms in
the United States from getting a damn
job
because if you're unclean it's going to
be really difficult for you to keep a
job after a while if you have no shelter
it becomes increasingly more difficult
if you can't shower or wash your clothes
it becomes increasingly more difficult
to hold a job
I never thought about it like that
[Music]
all right what's up what else
I'll tell you though man
you all been to see these videos of CVS
all these criminals breaking in there
stealing razors and baby food and all
kinds of whatnots and now they got
everything behind them
plexiglass I gotta ask a clerk just to
buy some goddamn Q-tips
why nobody care about the damn crime I
tell you California is uh
the loss is a lost State red states have
higher uh rates of crime than uh blue
states do on average that is but that is
a fact it doesn't matter if you don't
see it or not it's just the fact you're
watching too much television and it's
making you it's leading you with
straight it's making you believe that
blue states have higher rates of crime
when red States actually have high rates
crime but that's not because I've never
seen no video at CVS in a red State well
it doesn't matter just because there's
no video of it doesn't mean that it
doesn't exist you have to look at actual
data and not only that but also one
thing to consider here is that it's not
that red states are worse overall or
immoral it's simply that they're poorer
overall because crime is born out of
poverty I think people steal [ __ ] when
they don't have money you gotta
backwards I think people become poor
because they criminal minded ain't no
good if if the criminal minded became
poor more than Sam bankman freed would
be lose diet the guy who got arrested
recently in the Bahamas uh he's a
liberal he gave a lot of money to the to
the libtards well to Republicans as well
he's one of them Jews he is Jewish
I've seen that coming
tell you what boy ain't no surprise
there another Jew trying to make money
the easiest to wish uh I tell you what
though man crime is underreported in big
cities how they gonna look in every
island goddamn under every bus you know
as a crime happening all in every
goddamn corner of Los Angeles yeah how
you gonna report all that yeah that's
not true either the idea that crime is
underreported in big cities is just
something that you made up to justify
the position that crime is actually
decreasing everywhere across the board
regardless of the propaganda it just
makes sense I'm out here in Ohio ain't
nobody ain't nothing but a field man
stab another man we all see it over
right over there wait you're from Ohio I
don't know this is quite the Ohio
accident that you got here okay well
Ohio and Mississippi have pretty high
rates of crime too and so and so my
point is Hassan
boy uh-huh
would the hard be
you listen here boy
damn so many allies and Corners in Los
Angeles you ain't how you all gonna
report all that crime it don't make no
sense
[ __ ] yeah there's no evidence to
suggest that that's not a real thing
just logic it's not it's the opposite of
logic you're you're literally trying to
justify your own personal belief you
know like uh your favorite commentator
Ben Shapiro says you know facts over
feelings right that's right well yeah
well the facts of the matter show the
exact opposite of what you are
suggesting your problem is you trust the
data the data lie just like the Jews
where do you think the data comes from
Jews for crime statistics
come from Satan or does it come from the
police itself because that's where the
data comes from comes from the FBI and
it comes from the police themselves
right
well you got me there to be honest come
from the police I ain't no no position a
question there yeah do you think
I backed the blue no matter what yeah
I'll speak about speaking about the blue
here yeah I can't tolerate all this a
cab all this nonsense about defund the
police and all this man tell you every
single day our boys in blue out there
the most dangerous job in America not
true baby I heard a whole Fleet
got exposed to one grain of Fentanyl and
a whole platoon died on the spot yeah
and y'all want to talk about don't
respect it's also [ __ ] local media
coverage of fentanyl exposure within
cops is completely fabricated it's a
complete out all out nonsense uh if that
was the case if fentanyl exposure
through the skin could kill you like
that or could lead you into uh this this
shock which ironically fentanyl is not
supposed to like make you convulse like
that it's supposed to make you feel very
comfy and go to sleep because it's like
heroin
um yeah and it asphyxiates you but uh it
if that was the case in every EMT would
be dying on the regular because they
deal with the people with fentanyl
doctors I've seen this video on local
news yes but you are experiencing right
there it's their collapse after fentanyl
exposure what you were experiencing
right here is what is known as a panic
attack these cops are [ __ ] [ __ ]
and they ain't playing Attack how dare
you no that is absolutely a panic attack
and she is not she's all day and you've
seen here the police say it on camera he
said she's Odin that's the paramedic
yeah no she ain't how'd she knows that's
not how that works you can't you need
some kind of doctor that's a parent I
have talked to doctors and nurses
conservative doctors yeah like literal
doctors and EMTs and and uh nurses and
Fentanyl exposure to the skin uh has to
be done through like actual stickers
which is a way that you can do it right
you can put stickers on your body they
use it in hospitals all the [ __ ] time
and that kind of fentanyl specifically
uh that kind of Fentanyl
exposure is done through skin tears and
that still takes like a million stickers
in it and it feeds it into your body
over the course of like 24 hours 48
hours you would not be able to overdose
on that I'll tell you what man other
than that I had a friend named Jim Bob
he was walking past the local hospital
just taking a nice walk on a nice day
clock walk by an open window collapsed
they found so much fentanyl in his blood
it could have killed a whole elephant
how you explain that then your friend
did a lot of fan
that's how I explained it well he told
the normal through the normal processes
also he told the police caught a whip
from the window yeah cops are not
defunded that's also [ __ ] uh it's
almost as big as a [ __ ] story as the
whole like fentanyl exposure thing every
city across the board in the United
States of America has increased their
police budgets okay whenever people
point to a city where the police are
defunded they're they're talking about
um you know the additional funding that
they were going to get maybe they get a
little bit of a shaving off of that the
LAPD for example their budget is like
three billion dollars you think that you
think they have enough money they got a
lot enough crime I know that yeah well
they're not doing a good job I think
sure listen what do we do to people that
don't do a good job Uncle Nathaniel we
fire him right we just put them on the
street where they belong yeah well maybe
we should do that to the cops and and
get better cops or force them all I know
is crazy and we need them cops with
armored Shields and tanks and all all
kinds of [ __ ] yeah well you complain a
lot about the potholes in your Podunk
Town Uncle Nathaniel and a big part of
the reason why everything else a big
part of the reason why everything else
sucks in your small town is because uh
the 50 plus of the budget directly goes
into that militarized police force and
they're not even doing a good enough job
stopping Petty thefts and crime in your
city because they don't give a [ __ ]
here's a here's here's some data wrong
chart God damn it
that makes sense I guess you got a point
there huh all right maybe we could take
a little money out of the police to fix
a goddamn pothole you know yeah got a
damn pothole so big hit my wheel through
Straight off into the next County
hit my mama
Square in the head
now she got fentanyl in her blood
explain that
yeah I don't know if someone has fentyl
in their bloodstream they had to have
taken it like personally how dare you my
mama ain't no drug dealer my mom ain't
no drug habit
she just keeps sniffing it by
happenstance
coming in and out
open the window get a whiff of fentanyl
happens
happened to me the other day that's
impossible all right Democrats what else
you got Uncle Nathaniel
Democrats them just baby killers a
satanic them trying to get all them
abortions out if you want if you don't
want have an abortion don't be having
sex amen babies born the minute semen
goes into the egg that's what Jesus said
God Amen it might be maybe for you it
might be easy for you to never have sex
since Barbara left but uh you know
a lot of a lot of people do enjoy having
consensual sex this is a normal medical
process and don't complain when you get
pregnant that's the
that's the point of having sex y'all
want to be Godless well then live in
with little congregation people people
don't complain when they have sex and
then accidentally uh have a pregnancy a
lot of the times these are these
abortions are done out of uh
complications the majority of women that
get abortions in this country are women
that already have children as a matter
of fact so uh they're doing it either
Financial for financial reasons they're
doing it for other reasons like Health
complications in many instances and also
90 of abortions that are happening are
happening in the first trimester
regardless uh where you just go to a
Planned Parenthood or somewhere like
that and take uh take a pill and and
deal with it that way it's like it's
like a heavy flow period almost can't be
a little painful but it's a very simple
medical procedure and also making
abortions harder to get don't actually
stop abortions plenty of studies
conducted on this as well it simply just
makes uh it doesn't decrease the number
of abortions that are happening it just
turns them into back alley abortions
which lead to long-term complications uh
and and infertility in many instances as
a matter of fact or even death listen
yes and I don't know about what all you
just said all I know is about abortion
is murder
you support murder uh abortion is not
murder abortion you take on the human
life okay I mean you believe if someone
trespasses into your property and you
have a gun do you shoot them hell yeah
brother okay well then think about like
the fetus as a as a trespasser on your
property the fetus is trespassing if you
didn't know that it should exist inside
of your body well when I say take a gun
to the belly and shoot it off okay well
amen if we gonna put like that or
instead of that you could just go to the
doctor Stand My Ground against unwanted
fetuses okay there you go I'm glad that
we established that one Uncle Nathaniel
what's what's next I don't think you're
convincing anyone with that hogwash
though or is Satan working through them
Democrats
man I tell you man that
man I only support politicians who don't
get abortions like Trump and Herschel
Walker well I'm virtual man Herschel
Walker did get plenty of abortions what
and Donald Trump may have gotten an
abortion as well it would not be
surprising considering that Donald Trump
used to say that he was pro-choice and
pro-abortions anyway you might not want
to get an abortion and that's up to you
but uh well good thing you don't have a
[ __ ] or uh you know ovaries so you're
never gonna have to get that that's why
but that shouldn't stop the government
from interfering in in people's bodies
right listen I think make the government
small and stay out of people okay then
then they should stay out of people's
bedrooms and then they should stay out
of uh the multiple decisions in every
woman's vagina the government has one
special seat there okay that seems kind
of weird you know every time like I
don't think you think that the
government should interfere between a a
person and their doctor and their
private medical decisions right man
y'all heard um who's that great American
he said better
I believe abortion should be between a
man a woman a doctor that was Dr and the
local the local representative yeah
that's what I believe that was that's Dr
Oz good man yeah imagine if you uh went
to get your your insulin shot and you
know the the local cop troller was like
I don't think you should get insulin
today that's fair it's his that would
that be fair
all this talk about pro-life if you sell
pro-life man then what's with all this
covis vaccine more people died of the
vaccine than other damn covert is just
another flu they use in it to control us
we've been locked up good people we have
never been locked up
we were at Applebee's you were at
Applebee's first day when the lockdowns
were happening they said put on your
mask at the Applebee's and I never felt
more persecuted in my life I tell you
it's like 1960 persecution then you know
you need to you need to experience more
persecution in your life yeah I don't
know
it just seemed like a whole big Hub bub
over nothing and now it's gone and
everyone's fine it's not like one
million plus Americans died we took a
fat L to China even think about that
Uncle Nathan you wanna you wanna lose
the China those numbers been
exaggerate everyone who died doctors
like covet covered because they get
money every time I covered it's also not
true that was the case then why was
there one million additional deaths
according to the CDC or a give or take I
ain't never seen that uh well you know
if you look at the actual data from the
CDC there were a lot of extra deaths
that were unusual for that year in
comparison to Prior years and uh and
even now as a matter of fact in the
aftermath of coveted vaccines there's a
reason why covet is still going around
but the death rate is like significantly
lower it's because either people had it
and survived it somehow I don't know how
you survived it Uncle Nathaniel given
the shape that you're in and how many
times you've had coveted and and that
you were unvaccinated listen
but uh people either got it uh or they
uh were were immunized in some I left
lungs they have collapsed but I made it
out just fine yeah you you didn't make
it out just fine anyway
that fought you though I tell you man I
like that Elon Musk you talk about sins
um been tweeting out
pronoun and all that no I'm saying about
pronoun arrest fouchy
this man playing the whole damn thing
years ago he'd been in a I heard he'd
been with the Chinese planning the whole
damn covet virus well and all that [ __ ]
it was all it was all a plan by the
fauci I mean pandemic research has to be
done at the global level because like if
a virus starts in China okay
uh then uh you need to you need to be
readily available to combat it all
around the world as we saw with with uh
don't you think it's a little convenient
that fauci is with the Chinese
talking about coronavirus 10 years
earlier it's a Chinese virus in on it
well if you actually worked it with if
you worked in agriculture and you
actually had cows even though you LARP
as like a cowboy Uncle Nathaniel you
know that coronavirus is a very common
virus as a matter of fact covered
vaccines were readily available for the
cows ahead of time because this is
something that people were inoculating
they're missing the point if they're
cows with for a long time what you talk
about cows man I'm talking about fauci
and the chicken this is a this is uh
potentially a a zoonotic disease but
it's there's different variations
accuse me of what zoonotic uh spread I
never [ __ ] my cow how dare you don't
say that I was not saying that I did not
I don't think okay whatever son what you
do what you do is is up to you and your
cow okay that's between you and your cow
okay answer this then if that's work so
good then why are people still getting
sick huh well because a lot of people
are still on vaccinated and also the
vaccine uh is not you know 100 going to
eviscerate well then why am I even
getting a vaccine that don't even work
well it just significantly reduces the
chances of you getting it or getting
sick or getting really really sick when
you do end up getting covered because
you can't wear a mask anywhere you can I
work with this Feller he been vaxxed all
three times he got covered five times so
make no sense yeah well he didn't have a
lung collapse like you did Uncle
Nathaniel because he got the vaccine he
got the fauciology give me a moment okay
okay thank you so much
you know I just think it's all a big
cover-up you know you get banned on
Twitter for saying it was a Chinese
plant
the Chinese lab there and now it's
basically proven that the Chinese
release this from the lab it is not
proven at all
in a lot of instances as a matter of
fact it takes up to a decade to
successfully identify exactly what the
original uh what the original spread was
but uh these the consensus still among
scientists and an epidemic pandemic
researchers is that this is a zoonotic
spread if that's true
theory the Chinese live League theory
was originally created by the American
state department and was uh discredited
thoroughly and and early on even though
uh you know it's still a working Theory
it's still something that could have
possibly wow you get banned on Twitter
for talking about the lab League now you
can talk about it it's a cover-up from
the very start well Elon Musk goes
Twitter now so I think you can say
whatever you want on Twitter now uncle
Nathaniel good probably talk can finally
say the N word with no I don't think you
can say that um
he just means his own name Nathaniel
no I'm talking you know the word I'm
talking about nuclear nice guy
there it is nuclear it's the nuclear
word there oh okay I got it right of
course what'd you think I was talking
about y'all racist Pig you
Square for me piggy yeah I'll tell you
man I don't know man I'm glad that Cove
is over though and I'll tell you man
one thing that really itching my tits is
this zielinski fella uh-huh he's just as
bad as Putin you know I I think it take
two to tango and why we gotta be sending
them all kinds of funds anyway this
whole zelenski gonna take money from
good Americans and when we defunding the
police that don't make no sense at all
okay so
um
Ukraine is invaded by Russia which is a
larger country with a superior Firepower
so that's the reason why Western Nations
have decided to uh you know use Ukraine
as a funnel uh instead of Afghanistan
when uh when we withdrew out of
Afghanistan we had a 42 billion dollar
uh budget of weapons that we would sell
to the military industrial complex so we
decided to utilize the uh Russian
invasion for that fund we're also
testing new weapons out there as well
while we care what happened to Ukraine
I'm worried about what happened in here
in America we've got enough problems at
home well you know if it wasn't going to
be Ukraine it would have been somewhere
else regardless God damn it that place
too because uh the United States of
America's most viable most important
industry is our uh our our weapons amen
and uh if you think that that's a good
thing then you have to justify the war
in Ukraine or you have to say that it's
a good thing that we're giving billions
of dollars of weapons to Ukraine I do
believe in emancipation for the
Ukrainian people and I do think that
they deserve to get rid of the Russian
Invaders from their country well I heard
that zielinski is a Nazi and uh them
Russia exactly hold on there Hess and
let me finish my point okay
so Lansky and a bunch of radicals that
Russians in there it'll clear out the
Nazis now they don't sound like no bad
kind of thing do wait what them lot
Russians also have Nazis in their ranks
just like the ukrainians do the Russians
have the Wagner group that's like uh you
know you admit the Ukraine is full of
Nazis no I don't think Ukraine is full
of Nazis even though there are a lot of
nationalists in Ukraine uh who and and
there are certainly Nazis in Ukraine as
well uh given uh you know the Ukrainian
history of emancipation that is or
Ukrainian nationalism is tied with good
man he believes in traditional but I
don't think you hate nationalists do you
I mean I don't even know what that means
I just think Putin's a good man he's a
good Christian you don't believe no gay
people and he don't like Nazis I like
them don't worry and I love America
don't worry there's plenty of ukrainians
that don't like gay people either so
both sides on that front I don't know
who would agree with
I tell you though man it seems like I
just don't know why we got to be
fighting them fight for them it seemed
like we're not actually fighting they're
fighting for them they're fighting their
own fight we're just giving them weapons
so they can uh you know put up a better
fight I'll tell you what I'm rooting for
Putin why are you rooting for Putin
I've heard people I've heard
conservatives say that I don't know what
you left that is true the conservatives
do say that what's so funny about that
where did you get it from your telegram
channels where uh you know Vladimir
Putin is claiming to be uh the the
fighter against like Western degeneracy
I I just using my own logic because
Putin's a good man that's a landscape
represent
woke more or less
uh yes you've seen him talk about now
that's her mask now there's a real money
yeah I can't deny that that's that's
good that's hot there's that's what I
want if only it were real
what that's an image right there
the original is when oh I see you just
you just got fact checked my friend you
know you mean you can't ride a bear no
you can't ride a bear unfortunately
he does look good on that horse I will
give it to him on that one Vladimir
Putin I just feel that Russia gets a bad
rep they get all kinds of just cause
they a Christian Nation and all this and
people think they the bad guys but I I
think Putin's a good guy and I I don't
think the Russian people are bad people
necessarily I don't think that Putin is
a good person overall though he's been
you know authoritarian uh pretty much
dictator
uh who has uh single-handedly cost so
much cha almost single-handedly cost so
much chaos in uh Ukraine and in his own
country as well why are we what will we
want like a nuclear war with Russia Just
Let It Go just tell the language you
don't want to kill him to wrap it up
just tell him just be just let it down
the weapon as a matter of fact that's
interesting that you say that so you
happen to agree with a lot of
progressive voices then because the
Congressional Progressive caucus uh as a
matter of fact basically stated that uh
the American government should be
focusing on uh zielinski and and uh
urging zielinski to to restart
and peace negotiations in Russia and so
the Brandon Administration has also
alluded to that as well so you agree
with Joe Biden on that front I guess I
do I just don't see the point of the
whole day though you would never agree
with Joe Brandon Uncle Nathaniel well
when you're doing this you break a
character here a little bit Yeah well
listen when he's right he's right for
example I saw Voodoo bet him back 2008
so talking about he don't believe in gay
marriage and I said I did a holler and a
woo I backed him up back then and I
think he's a good man he's just seen
what he need to be saying I know in his
heart he don't like the gays just like
me
don't worry Ukraine doesn't like the
gays either well thank God you've got
nothing to worry about thank God for
that boy
it's not liberal media has been lying to
everyone yeah Dan Ukraine is gay as hell
like don't worry they're they're not
what when I was 12 I used to have a boy
my best friend we used to bathe together
well we used to get kind of real close
like we were close friends and one time
we got real close in the tub and he sent
my lap and Mama it started to move I rub
on it very uncomfortable situation that
was the last time I saw when I was made
naked and well sometime I think about
that little ball one where he's at but
anyway I don't like the gays and uh okay
let's move on from this weird story
Uncle Nathaniel I'm just trying to make
a point lay off the eggnog Maybe
but another eggnog
that's a big game man
I like the Santas though I tell you man
all this talk though about him running
against Trump is a load of [ __ ]
because Trump
as I understand it
is still the president
why are you laughing I've just you know
I agree he is the president he's the
president of my heart too and and and
I'll tell you man it was antifa January
6. everybody's seen it
and Uncle Nathaniel you were there
there's photos of you inside of Nancy
Pelosi's room
with your feet on her desk I was invited
that day and God damn I'm America those
chambers belong to America but how do
you want trespassing your own home you
were there with all your friends you
guys flew in from Arkansas specifically
to go to it I didn't and you guys
stormed the halls I don't know none of
that mother there were no antifa there I
think there was a couple
no it was all you guys and and also you
keep saying it was actually a good thing
you keep you justify it right it's like
unjust that the election was stolen so
you think it's a good thing that you
know you try to fight back well Trump so
here's where you roam there's the TR the
election was all kind of a pretense to
have Trump stay as president he actually
never let the people go he run from the
shadows and uh well he's just waiting
for tomorrow he's coming back you
originally stated that it was Biden's
fault for inflation if Trump is still
secretly running the government doesn't
that mean that Trump is responsible for
inflation then well Trump's kind of like
a break he's online so you're saying he
took a break you took a break from
running the country that seems a little
irresponsible you're like a vampire what
the [ __ ] he doing playing golf
probably ain't nothing wrong with got a
little golf now anyway as far as
DeSantis goes you know he's he's a fake
Trump he's trying to beat Trump he wants
to be Trump
I don't like him either I think you get
in line and you stay in line Trump's a
good man he's our leader he's done so
much for us over the past years and I
don't like the scientists trying to come
at him I don't think we need any of that
I agree but also uh you know mainstream
conservative media is propping up to
Santa's because they think he's a
controllable uh uh person unlike Trump
who just kind of does his own thing
which is why I like him right he's his
own man yeah well you know I do like
what the scientists did when he filmed
those immigrants up to Martha's uh yeah
that was [ __ ] his Vineyard at least
he saved them from the plight of Florida
and like God
I'll tell you what man I had sharks in
there just sink them boats right there
in the water I'll tell you that's okay
that's that's just you just want to
murder immigrants then Uncle Nathaniel
that's crazy well
these are Venezuelan immigrants too and
they're like escaping communism as a
matter of fact they have specific
amnesty as a consequence of like their
Venezuelan Asylum status so what
DeSantis did is like additionally [ __ ]
up and not only that but also even
people in Florida didn't appreciate that
move because there's a lot of
Venezuelans living in Florida right wing
Venezuela is living in Florida State and
communism yeah yeah
I know I don't not really but
oh not really what you mean by that I
think that because there's not like a
real communist country Venezuela is not
a communist Nation I think we need more
border control more boats and I think we
need to outfit them with mini guns and
missiles just
shoot them like fishing up there you
think that's what Jesus would want ah
Jesus would
[ __ ] Jesus okay he's a queer what okay
let's move on
Jesus was a little ninny
talking about
prostitutes
single parents
anyway
it's terrible what they've done to Mr
Kanye West he's a good man he's just
always speaking the truth
what ain't anyone ever point out that
the Jews run the media and the banks
whatever happened to free speech then
okay uh well Kanye West still is not in
jail or anything so he's uh very much
allowed to keep spreading false
conspiracies about like Jewish people
running the banks and the media or any
meaningful capacity which is not true
now
um there is no there is no like
monolithic uh there is no like singular
uh Jewish idea uh that they're acting
out on they're just rich people some of
them happen to be Jews and they're just
doing rich people [ __ ] man you ever seen
this red list though if you look at all
the Jews and maybe I mean half those
people weren't even Jews it was just
that was a list made by some [ __ ]
weird losers that never leave their
houses you know you're telling me Kanye
West walking around with the XL file
yeah he ain't never even fact checked it
yes of course he hasn't because his best
friend is a little goober Nazi you like
that kid the the Netflix
he got his head on straight he's a 23
year old shut-in who still lives in his
mother's basement and eats his own
boogers that's what that's the kind of
guy you think is good that don't sound
so good when he plays I love Hitler yeah
kids love Hitler man also we defeated
Hitler if you remember you know America
back when America was great in World War
II so
yeah that's true I don't like the Nazis
you're right yeah there you go so but I
just feel like Mr Kanye West get a bad
rap probably because he just walked
around with Maga hat he wants to love
Trump now everybody will call him an
anti-semitic no I mean he was still
making albums and and still being uh
accepted into like liberal Society uh
when he was saying that he loves Donald
Trump is when he started saying that he
loves Adolf Hitler that's when people
were like oh okay this is a bridge too
far for me
right I see I guess I see your point on
that you know you know but I tell you
man you've seen that you know must rub
on them Twitter files talk about how
Biden was covering up for his son's
beautiful [ __ ] and leafs leaked out do
you want to see Hunter Biden's penis I
have many times son that's kind of weird
oh wow it's revenge porn illegal as well
yeah I'm doing due diligence as a free
citizen yeah I'm on Twitter talk about
them covering up the whole Hunter Bond
laptop store man and I'll tell you I've
seen all kinds of evil pictures on that
laptop I'm talking about he's also got
very well endowed
massive arrest that makes me feel Uncle
Nathaniel well it made me feel all kind
of thing but mostly disgust why were you
disgusted seeing this fat one I had to
look real closely at it yeah I looked
real close and long at that well maybe
it's a good thing that other people
aren't feeling the same feelings if
they're robbing they're not letting the
revenge porn uh you know spread on on
Twitter well but it don't have an
important Point like why wouldn't buy
and he's so corrupt man he take money
from the Ukraine he talking about all
kinds of smoking crack and all this [ __ ]
he did take money from berezma that's
true that did exactly what the trumps
did uh which is nepotism uh trading the
name of Biden for a job that he didn't
deserve just like Ivanka he's a
crackhead on it just like industry yeah
just like the the the trumps like Trump
Jr and Eric Trump they did the exact
same thing yeah but Trump's a smart man
he's playing the system and he's being
upfront about it
yeah well then Biden is doing it too I
guess they're both pretty but he lied
about it but I'll tell you man what's he
on like a energy panel [ __ ] goddamn
crackhead on Angie Panda don't make no
sense it doesn't make sense it's just as
silly as uh you pass a crack pop round
just as silly as uh you know putting
Ivanka in a position of power or Jared
Kushner in a position of power I like
that within the American with the
American government well Jerry Christian
is also Jewish I thought I thought you
didn't like Jewish people I like that I
said oh okay well she's Jewish too now
she converted
[Applause]
her blood is pure and that's all oh okay
got it yeah I'll tell you man though but
if you do find any more of those hunting
picks you won't send me me I'll verify
them okay yeah I will do that for you if
I find any more Hunter bodies I'm
keeping a folder for my record because I
know they scrubbed the internet of them
took pictures I keep a folder on my
desktop called hunting Biden's penis and
it's just in case these cries wipe it
from the internet I got them all
close-ups I got fire UPS I got printouts
and I got Zoom ins I got every angle man
you tell me when I got it okay it's good
to know that you have every angle of
Hunter Biden's penis well I'm a good
American Daniel do you have anything
else Uncle Nathaniel to discuss don't
yeah I just well don't go uh don't go in
the basement under the floorboards all
right son what what what does that mean
I said it again don't you go Snoop
around those floorboards I don't know
what that means Uncle Nathaniel well
it's none of your business but just know
that I love
picking up
hitchhikers what
that's right
Uncle okay you gotta lay off the sauce a
little bit and the eggnog is fine no
I'll tell you something little man I'll
tell you something on my mind
back in 09 I picked up a hitchhiker fine
little man hit the um fresh fish what
but he brought him back to the house
had a few drinks ask them where he's
gone
Jeffrey dahmers things got a little
heated he came on to me tried to give me
a kiss I say ain't like that
give him a little kiss
started tassel around a little push
little Pope
trying to get you're trying to ride me
trying to get on me trying to kiss me
I'll hold him down
I was only defending myself fishing
swear I didn't mean to do it
okay
took a knife to Uncle Uncle Dahmer
yeah that sounds very similar to Dominic
I didn't mean to do it
I took it
I took a knife to him she'll hurt myself
watched him bleed out on the floor there
I never forget to look into the boy's
face as he stared me down flow
it's a lot faded from his eyes and I
I knew I would never be the same after
that one
I never even caught his name but I put
him out
cut them up in the little pieces in a
trash bag and put them under the house
soon
been a couple wolves come by try to dig
up the remains but I didn't get them
down track them down put them back in
there a little deeper now
[Music]
sometimes I think I hear that boy's
voice coming in there when I'm sleeping
echoing in from the basement like trees
and leaves
soft winter blood
hmm there's one thing I never
[Music]
one thing I
I never did say to that boy
said I liked it
I did like it
should have found shouldn't have found
him
how my life would have been different if
I would have accepted that kiss and
well
I better not I better lay off the eggnog
for the evening getting low
yeah sidetracked yeah maybe but I did
preserve his penis all right okay all
right an amazing job it's time for bed
Uncle Nathaniel we we are actually out
of time Amanda that's true yeah we are
we are out of time uh I made a mold out
not even a joke oh my God
all right leftovers is going on great on
vacation that's it that's what we're
leaving the people with
keep it by my bedside good thing uh
Ethan will be coming on my podcast you
can say when I'll be there because you
promise not his uncle Nathaniel I'll
come as myself I'm out of yeah I get
deep into and you did you got that was
scary yeah sorry man I looked into your
eyes for a moment and I I did not see
Ethan staring back at me it was Uncle
Nathaniel you had become one with Uncle
Nathan I was gotten deep in the
character boy
yeah but uh you when you wear that hat
some changes in you yeah I'm gonna take
this off for the last time this year
okay retiring this afternoon
but that's it I hope you know Hassan I
hope you have a great holiday
I will try I will try to go to sleep
tonight uh and and try to feel safe ever
again yeah well
I know what I know I promise about Uncle
Nathaniel
yeah but it's been a great year it has
been a good evening fun time I'm really
enjoying uh
really enjoying what we're doing here
and we'll be back next year for another
great year as we come closer to uh
DeSantis yeah building up to the
ultimate battle God that is scary 2023
this is like actual presidential primary
scenes and it's gonna dude it's gonna
happen next year's gonna rule dude yeah
it's gonna be so much fun when does that
usually kick it it's like summer
probably like summer of next year is
when they'll start being these are a
little different now because Donald
Trump is you know early right let's see
what happens I don't know I'm excited
it's gonna be so much fun but anyway I
hope you have a great holiday and I will
see you guys and you you tell me when
you want to be there I'll be there all
right perfect you're talking about like
at your house on your stream yeah well
that's where I film my podcast too so I
just sit there like one of your one of
your girls I mean I have guys on too
so yeah
should I wear something skimpy and small
or just show up sure okay
where yeah wear something push up bro
yeah don't worry I got the angles locked
down you are not gonna look there's no
side profile We're not gonna have any
moments yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I love that it's all
flattering angles baby love that speak
to me talk to me all right
um thank you guys for supporting this
show this throughout this whole year
it's been a crazy experiment the
leftovers you know political show
it's not always easy
but a couple couple beef B jokes a
couple of G jugs we made it through the
year in one piece
we did yeah we're live and alive still
somehow
all right guys and by the way when we
come back despite Ethan's best attempts
we have not been permanently banned from
the internet
and knock on wood not to jinx it but
when we come back from break
we'll have no strikes
wow
knock on wood I mean we're back there
two episodes left we're back to Ethan
Unleashed then huh we have two episodes
oh no I'm gonna try to chain myself up
but you know yeah they say about chained
animals instead of chaining Jesus up
Jesus was uh in the chat today by the
way and donated uh quite a few super
chats so shout out to Jesus did he
forgive me yeah he says he loves all of
his children and then he did uh American
flag uh uh pride flag and a trans pride
flag so uh that don't sound like the
Jesus on them
yeah anyway guys listen
that's it that's it for the year so
thank you Hassan thank you to everybody
and this is The Leftovers signing out
[Music]
oh
foreign